c'est une information qui est tombée en
fin d'après-midi le footballeur argentin
diego maradona légende interplanétaire
de la discipline est décédé à l'âge de
60 ans mais annonce chahuté car d'abord
démentie par là et fait suite à
plusieurs rumeurs persistantes sur les
réseaux sociaux avant d'être finalement
confirmée par le porte parole du joueur
la mort d'une légende du football la
mort de diego maradona est confirmée
malheureusement cet immense joueur de
football et les années 80 maradona
s'impose comme un joueur de génie
après deux ans au fc barcelone c'est à
naples qu'il vit ses grandeurs entre
1984 et 1991
celui qui est surnommé le gamin en or
s'impose au napoli comme un dieu et qui
va mal mais une star du ballon rond qui
en 1986 sera rayonner l'argentine en
remportant la coupe du monde au mexique
[Applaudissements]
pour à ce jour il est l'auteur de
quelques unes des plus belles actions du
football mondial
en 2019 diego maradona est nommé
entraîneur du club de gimnasia y esgrima
la plata
une vie et une carrière exceptionnelle
qui a pris fin aujourd'hui
et il est aussi l'auteur d'une séquence
qui restera gravé dans l'histoire de la
fameuse main de dieu on l'appeler la
main de dieu c'est lord anglais lord en
plaques ou du monde 86 face à
l'angleterre
il a marqué un but de la main ou lisicki
a fait comme ça en fait regardez c'était
où ça je crois que c'était maintenant
adena que l'anglais arrive à contenir
soit pas trop mal jusqu'ici le ring side
et ça devient dangereux il finalement
raté maradona qui récupère on dirait
qu'il ya main maradona jubile le but est
accordé
ouais voilà maradona serré un des plus
grands joueurs de tous les temps où très
vite soit par à nous on pense que c'est
un très joueur un grand très grand
joueur de foot maradona en france et en
argentine c'est comme un dieu maradona
di gloria alors je vais vous dire ce
qu'ils ont décrété l'argent qu'on à jour
nodo la mort exact trois jours de deuil
national à jour de deuil national pour
maradona
pour moi c'était plus grand joueur de
tous les temps
c'était un jour exceptionnel c'est
quelqu'un qui a eu des addictions
pendant toute sa vie la cocaïne l'alcool
il a suggéré quand il était encore en
activité mais malheureusement
contrairement à d'autres grandes
légendes du foot comme zidane comme paul
il n'a pas su gérer l'après il a été
rattrapé par ses démons et ses priorités
entre une fois ah oui oui à paris sait
plus quel truc à la con mais il troque
alors serre qui transpirait certes il
était sous influence certains n'était
pas dans son état normal mais même comme
ça
il dégageait un truc inouï suis vraiment
vraiment animal et moi j'avais été
extrêmement impressionnés ils n'étaient
plus que lui mais pourtant ils étaient
là qui était aujourd'hui j'ai eu dû mal
à y croire
voilà